from restaurants to writers to kung-fu
flicks whether you realize it or not our
culture has been shaped by Chinese
immigrants their kids and their
grandkids I'm jolly welcomes aj+ this
Sunday we're gonna talk to you about why
people left China in the first place and
how they ended up here in the US
[Music]
Chinese people have been coming to the
US for more than 150 years to pursue
economic opportunities escape political
unrest and seek higher education to help
make this explanation easier we're gonna
break this down into four periods the
over four million Chinese people live in
the u.s. today at the beginning these
numbers are pretty small the first group
of immigrants left because of political
instability and news of golden jobs in
California back in the 1850s the cities
up and down the Pearl River Delta
including Guangzhou were hubs for
international trade many people in this
area left to pursue better opportunities
abroad at the same time the Taiping
rebellion and the opium wars led others
to Fleet poverty and instability
meanwhile gold was discovered in
California and extra hands were needed
to build the Transcontinental Railroad
and these forces kicked off the first
wave of Chinese immigration but what
started out as job opportunities in
America took an ugly turn discrimination
and violence white laborers felt like
Chinese immigrants were threatening
their jobs and took extreme measures to
get rid of them they burnt down China
towns publicly Lynch Chinese people and
pass racially targeted laws this is how
we ended up with the Chinese Exclusion
Act the first US law restricting
immigration based on race after the act
was passed the Chinese population
started to drop until World War two at
the start of World War two Japan had
invaded China for the second time most
intensively bombs but in all the world
is the wartime capital of pre-cana
by the end of the war 15 million Chinese
people had died and China was in a
communist nationalist civil war China
and the u.s. became allies to defeat
Japan but the Chinese Exclusion Act was
still in place so the very people who
were fighting alongside the Americans
were not even allowed to come into the
country after World War 2 the u.s.
realized this irony and repealed the
laws boost mostly for appearance an
immigration quota was set for just 105
Chinese immigrants each year
by 1945 the war brides Act passed this
law allowed spouses and children to join
men in the US before then the Chinese
immigrants were mainly made up of
bachelors and from here the
chinese-american community really
started to develop in this third period
immigrants left because Mao's policies
led to widespread famine and persecution
of many people including intellectuals
life got even more desolate in the 1950s
and 60s the Great Leap Forward Mouse
campaigns industrialized the country
caused one of the worst famines of the
20th century
soon after Mao launched a Cultural
Revolution a campaign to purge a country
of everyone deemed Western or bourgeois
including students professors and
doctors the revolution was violent and
bloody this changed the makeup of who
left China those who had the means to
and were willing to risk their lives
fled and here's journalist John pomfrit
the former bureau chief of the
Washington Post in China to explain why
this was so important the push factor
from China was the chaos the political
backbiting the attacks on Western
education that were being carried out by
Mazda villain in the Communist Party and
that pushed huge numbers of Chinese to
vote with their feet by going to Hong
Kong and then getting access to United
States through family reunification
meanwhile the civil rights movement was
in full swing leading to the passage of
the Immigration Act of 1965 officially
ending the hundred and five quota here
the Chinese population really started to
pick up the majority came from Hong Kong
and Taiwan including some mainland
Chinese refugees and many were coming to
study in American universities by this
time the Chinese population had shifted
from mainly blue-collar workers to
white-collar workers from 1950 to 1960
the Chinese population doubled after Mao
died Deng Xiaoping came to power he was
known for opening up the Chinese economy
to more free-market principles by 1990
we started seeing signs of a growing
economy in China
despite the economic reforms China's
government remains strict on protests
and public dissent when the Tiananmen
Square crackdown happened in 1989 over
70,000 Chinese students got permanent
residency in the u.s. the following year
the u.s. introduced the eb-5 visa
something that allowed rich foreigners
to essentially buy permanent residency
with half a million to a million dollar
business investment this program wasn't
that popular in its first 18 years but
that really started to change as China's
economy skyrocketed today's immigrants
are wealthier than they have been in the
past most believe are looking to pursue
business opportunities live in a better
environment and get an American
education China's economy has really
taken off in the last 20 years by 2010
their extreme poverty rate fell to 12
percent down from nearly 90 percent in
1981 that happened in less than 40 years
and this completely changed who wanted
to emigrate to the United States here's
Sean pomfret again to explain how
today's immigrants are different from
immigrants of the past the push factor
is now moreso issues of potential
economic opportunity the search for a
better life clean food cleaner air
cleaner water compared to the 90s
Chinese immigration slowed down at the
turn of the century the economic boom in
China created more opportunities at home
so in the last few minutes we told you
about more than a hundred years of
immigration history from the poor to the
persecuted to the wealthy the Chinese
American story ranges and like all
immigrants there's always been more than
one side the dreams of a better life and
the challenges they've left behind you
guys we just did a three-part series
that looks like Chinese American
immigration and diaspora in the US
through the lens of food so if you liked
this take a look at our series don't
forget to like share and subscribe and
see you guys next Sunday